It's the magical moment Harry Potter fans had been waiting and wishing for.
Muggles across the globe will be able to get their hands on the latest story...
...in the Harry Potter franchise.
"Let the feast begin!"
The story release coinciding with the theatrical version...
...opening on the British stage.
Millions of fans going hog wild for Hogwarts...
...and soon, finally finding out what adventures now await the wizarding world.
Fans of Potter will be hitting bookstores tonight.
Parties planned to celebrate the nearly 10-year wizard drought.
I'm really excited about the book.
Peter Glasman hosting such a party at his store here in New York City,...
...ready to welcome fans to share in the excitement.
The story's under tight security until tonight's festivities.
We'll be having crafts going on, trivia contests, all sorts of things, all night long.
Harry Potter casting a spell on the literary world once again.
You're a wizard, Harry.
Amazon and Barnes and Noble reporting Harry Potter and the Cursed Child...
...is their most pre-ordered book since the last Harry Potter release.
It's definitely very interesting that it is the script.
Seeing how the fandom reacts to that is going to be really interesting to watch.